do you know about a certain man named
gotham adani have you ever heard this
name before i don't remember what what's
this
donnie just became this guy just became
the third richest man in the world
and so yes the indian guy from uh uh
he's kind of like a
and he owns like a huge mansion and down
in downtown like mumbai where like it
it's like a skyscraper yeah so he uh so
he elon musk number one jeff bezos
number two and now adani number three
and so people they watch this list and
they're like who's who is adani
[Music]
all right in this episode we're talking
about the third richest man in the world
somebody who you've never heard of we
talked about team zuck so basically
zuckerberg has this new video of him
doing mma and we did a little recap on
how we feel about it but also we kind of
looked at how he makes his decisions and
what our perspective is on him and i
actually think it's quite interesting we
broke down one of mr b's to me the most
interesting business that mr beast has
that nobody else is really talking about
and i think is loki
a star business so that's the episode
give it a listen let us know what you
think and write in the comments go on
youtube write in the comments i'll be
replying to every single comment that's
in here with something that's either
smart or funny i guarantee it go to the
comments and leave one and i'll be back
all right i have a fun one this will get
us in the mood so kanye west
pop culture
uh do you follow kanye
of course i don't really pay attention
to kanye west really uh it's not really
on my uh radar but he did something kind
of funny and we talked about him
yesterday and it's business related but
basically you know he's having this like
tizzy with adidas do you know about that
no and nice use of tizzy you like that
uh well and frankly i don't entirely
know about it so i'm just gonna kind of
like summarize but basically you know
kanye worked with adidas to launch
yeezys his line of shoes um it's
collectively made like or not
collectively but in 2020 easy sales were
1.17 billion dollars in revenue he made
around 200 million dollars from that so
he made a lot of money and basically
he's having a fight with them i don't
actually know what the fight is about
but the backstory is that he's accused
them of stealing his designs and leaving
him out of meetings for their yeezy shoe
collaborations sean uh combs you know
diddy said he's gonna boycott because of
this and kanye has said i'm gonna make
things unbearable for you guys until you
comply so i don't exactly know what
comply means but what's kind of it's
both sad because like it looks like he's
going through some stuff and it is funny
and he's kind of trying to be funny and
it's working but he basically said i've
got no chill it's going to cost you guys
billions to keep me it's going to cost
you billions to let me go adidas you
stole my design among
other things and i'll give you until
tuesday not until the seven months that
i told you originally i was going to
give you today's the day like he like
went like he's going crazy and
on his
twitter which he's got like i don't know
how many followers
tens of millions i would imagine
he's posting
each person's picture who's on the board
of directors as well as a couple other
boards like they have a board of
advisories uh of adidas's people and so
he posted this one woman who's also and
he's like it'll say stuff about him like
sometimes it's funny but sometimes it's
like this woman's on the board of uh
adidas she's also chairman and
investment banker at jp morgan i went to
jp morgan in order to raise money for my
buyout and they wouldn't do it like he's
going kind of bananas and i thought that
that was wild and then i saw another
thing that he's he's having another
tizzy with
uh his wife kim or ex-wife about a
school and i went and looked at their
school have you heard about this so he
has his own school right like he has his
own academy or something like that
yeah so he's trying to start this thing
called donda so donda.org if you go
there it actually looks
weird but interesting and kind of fun
like it looks cool and if you go to
about on how we learn
you'll see like they describe the
curriculum and it's like it kind of
makes sense but then you see like weird
things like if you look at what the
daily schedule it says after school
parkour well
first of all i went to the site
donda.org it's just like who we are how
we learn admissions and choir those are
the top four links which is just quiet
yeah which of these does not belong i
don't know why choir is up here
secondly
there's just like a white i don't even
know what it looks like a white pigeon
to be honest with you just flapping its
wings in slow-mo okay it's like a fat
dove though it's not it's not like a
sleek graceful dub it's like a chunky
guinea pig yeah
it's a guinea pig with wings that's just
flying up in slow motion and that's the
website i'm gonna click how we learn
because i can't not um okay they got
less than 12 students per per class rule
number one
should be students should be confident
in forming or forming ideas if not their
writing will suffer okay so their daily
schedule full school worship okay that's
a good way to start the day how we
similar to how we start the pod
um yeah core classes lunch and recess
enrichment classes including
film choir and you're right parkour
a bunch of singing ninjas out here just
singing and flipping around
so i thought this was interesting
because uh it you know even though he's
i don't like laughing at him a guy if
he's going kind of insane but he's
trying to be funny with this instagram
thing and it kind of is hilarious uh
like he posted like the a guy i think
the ceo of sa sap uh or is it sap yeah
the like the hr software that nobody
actually understands what they do he
like tweeted out or uh instagramed his
this guy's face and goes you are a sap
that's what he said and it just
it's just
all right he's just doing the most
childish immature thing and it's so
funny it is working it's awesome and
then this school thing i saw because of
his other little fight with kim and he's
like
anyway
i don't know how this is related to
business but i i thought that you would
have know about this because you're more
of a pop culture guy than i am no but
let me tell you uh okay so this is
here's a theme for this episode i'm
gonna call it
people with giant egos
you know i'm going to call it because i
don't actually know if these people have
giant egos i'm going to say
creative titans that's better
creative titans so the first one is
going to be
my billy of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
what's cool
a billion dollars
do you know about a certain man named
gotham adani have you ever heard this
name before
uh
um
i don't remember what what's this
donnie just became this guy just became
the third richest man in the world
and so yes the indian guy from uh uh
he's kind of like a
and he owns like a huge mansion and down
in downtown like mumbai where like it
it's like a skyscraper yeah so he uh so
he elon musk number one jeff bezos
number two and now adani number three
and so people they watch this list and
they're like who's who is adani and i
actually i don't know if i met him but
we definitely pitched him i think my dad
pitched him a business thing many years
ago my dad always kept saying oh we just
need to get a donnie on board adani
adani adani and so i'd heard about this
guy before
and i didn't you know and his net worth
has just skyrocketed because his stock
is up like 13x in the last item is this
reliant industries no so reliance it was
the top kind of like company there and
the guy who runs it mukesh and bonnie
was the
i think he was he was the richest man in
india and now adani has passed him up in
the last year because his stock went up
13x so so who is this guy and what does
he do okay so um
what he does you'll you'll appreciate
this
is he a software guy is he a mark
zuckerberg no no he's not is he elon
musk is he trying to create the future
of uh you know space travel and you know
like brain computer interfaces no
this guy operates at a place that sam
likes
power so he does coal
ports
plastics you know [__] like that so
basically this guy's like
they do they do like industrial work and
so he owns when so when he was he was a
kid he was in school he went to go visit
this port it was the largest port in the
country at the time a port you know
where literally like ships come in and
out and um he's like inspired by it was
like one day i'm going to own the
biggest port ever and the biggest board
in india and now he's sure enough he
owns the biggest port in india he owns
the most ports in india too um with the
deal we were trying to do with him we
were trying to get adani to come to
australia to build a port for our
startup that was based in australia
because these guys were the kings of
ports but his story is pretty cool he's
a he's a college dropout so 18 drops out
he
becomes a diamond sorter i don't even
know what that means but he became a
diamond sword he got an interest in the
diamond business
and after a couple years of sorting
diamonds he then goes and he starts his
own diamond brokerage and he's like i
will trade i will basically age of 20 as
a diamond broker
brother calls him up brother says hey
brother i have a uh a small plastic
factory here that i i own now i've i
bought or i run and so he helps him go
scale up the plastic factory and then as
he's doing that he's like oh let's start
importing the like the materials that
come up you know upstream of plastics
and so he starts doing he creates like
an export company and so he just keeps
creating these companies so now he has
seven publicly listed companies he's got
the adani group which is like the the
mega one and then they'll start like
adani power adani um you know like
trading adani
real estate or whatever they'll start
all these different companies they'll
take them all public
and what's interesting about it is that
and he's got a beautiful mustache by the
way yeah
you know the meme account dr park patel
he looks like the meme accounts photo
actually so
i don't know if it's if it's him or just
looks a lot like him he looks like a
like an indian
mario
you know like mario and luigi
he looks like an idiot mario like you
know
you look he does
you know when mario does that little
squat like right you know when you want
to you want to do that trick or you go
behind the thing you're standing on and
you run and you get the magic yeah he's
like squatting he's a little squatty
squatty version of indian mario
so
anyways this guy has now become you know
whatever the third person he's got these
crazy stories he was i don't know if you
know there was like this um sort of like
an indian 911 thing where there's like a
terrorist attack on a hotel he was in
that hotel and he was like in the
hostage group that was there wow he was
also kidnapped at one point in time and
taken ransom for two million dollars
they paid it and got free and so this
guy has just lived this like kind of
crazy life
and even now
he's doing really well the group's doing
really well he's third richest man on
earth there is a
set of people who are very very
skeptical about what these guys are
doing because
they have so much debt in their
companies like he is basically
constantly trying to acquire companies
like they just bought the largest cement
producer in india but they buy these
companies using debt and he's got this
intricate like set of companies and so
there's a big question of like is this
all a house of cards that's going to
fall over and you're going to see a guy
go from the number three richest to like
you know falling off the list completely
or is he actually going to pull this off
because what they'll do is
they'll say okay the the parent company
has some profits we'll take a loan on
that
and then they take like one of the new
companies public like oh adani green
power and they'll take the green company
public because it's got the adani name
stock price goes up and then he'll
invest in it from the parent company and
then he'll sell those shares and then
he'll borrow against the
stock and then he'll issue a bond and
he's got like all these different debt
instruments and so they have i think
more debt than like any other company in
india and now there's a question of is
this all going to fall over is it all
going to work it's pretty fascinating
dude when do do you ever feel i feel
self-conscious when i hear about these
things because
my
like my thing with business is like just
the very simple of buy low sell high you
know like i purchase a widget for you
know one dollar and i put some type of
value or i just buy tons of them and so
i get a discount and then i sell them
for like a dollar fifty that fifty cents
my profit i use a quarter a quarter of
that to pay myself a quarter to go buy
more
and like it's like a relatively like
simple straightforward process and then
i hear about like you just use the word
debt instruments and how he you know he
like he does this thing and gets a loan
across this thing and this thing and
when i hear that stuff i just think like
so
like where's the dollar that goes into
his bank account actually come from you
know what i mean like right like i try
to think about i'm like i don't
understand how this person then
eventually collects the money and how
the people who are owed money where they
got the money from and when they're
going to get paid back like do you know
what i mean it's like it's so
complicated for me because i'm such a
simpleton or
is it just [__] dude i don't think i
was in seventh grade my parents got me a
piano teacher
and i wish that instead i just learned
how to play dead instruments like that
would have just been so much better than
learning how to play you know what do
you mean
[Laughter]
where do people learn this stuff where
do people learn this sort of financial
engineering i think that a lot of it
happens if you're like on the inside so
you work at a investment bank or you
work somewhere there but like this guy
didn't but this guy didn't do that yeah
yeah so you know i think he hired people
who who do that and they sort of [__]
say hey look here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna we're gonna issue this bond
and we're gonna take this company public
that we're gonna like take a load pledge
the shares we're gonna get a loan
against the shares and basically somehow
one dollar of ebitda has become eight
dollars of you know cash flow for us and
like we got to figure out how to do that
without it all
collapsing but people like when you
understand financial engineering they
have such an edge such an
edge
but when i like originally like made
some money and i remember like our
bankers saying like yeah you could
borrow money now at one percent and i'm
like yeah i don't want to go into debt
and they'd be like well no sometimes
it's like it could be wise for you to do
that for example you have to pay taxes
i'm like why he goes well because you'd
have to sell this thing which then you'd
take like a you know a 40
discount on that because the taxes and
i'm like wait i don't understand this
can you like lay this out like can you
write this on a piece of paper so like
it and then my banker griffin he ended
up flying to new york to visit me to
like he goes dude i just need to sit
down with you so you understand this i
swear to god i swear i go why are you
coming here you got meetings he goes no
i'm coming to explain this to you so he
gave and he explained it to me
yeah sure meetings uh yeah
i've cleared my day to explain the one
concept of borrowing against doc
like i just didn't understand it were
you the same way where you're like i
just don't get this this doesn't make
sense no
you and others explained it to me right
so like yes it's true i didn't
understand i didn't know about it at
first and then when i knew about it i
didn't understand why it was good and
then somebody's like hey so you notice
why this is amazing right
you could either sell your stock pay
taxes and no longer own the stock
or you could keep owning the stock never
pay the taxes just borrow at a one
percent rate against that money and like
you're good
and i was like
okay so that's good right they're like
all right you [__] you didn't
understand like let's do this again
yeah i just like so these financial
engineers you know where i learned a lot
about this stuff is from ben our ben
wilson his uh
podcast with rothschild like i and like
i started like learning about this a
little bit but then i also learned that
i think some people i don't know like
what skill set it is i do think it's
rooted in just like they're just good at
math and they understand um
just like complicated algebra to be
honest just like exponential exponential
like that that's a concept that's like
it sounds like i'm joking but that's
actually quite hard to understand like
to understand what a seven percent or 10
or 12 growth for 50 periods what's that
actually look like like i remember
listening to this podcast i was like oh
you're just like just like lebron it's
just taller and can dunk better it
doesn't matter what i do like there's
some people that are just better at this
and i don't know what that skill set is
but there is something there there it's
like you're just you're better than me
well i think you just get curious about
that thing which most of us who are like
builders makers entrepreneurs
you know like the stereotype about let's
say um
you know
who cares what you know corporate
structure
uh bookkeeping taxes like you know
whatever
raising debt that wasn't never the
reason i got into business that's not
what i found interesting at the time
i was like you it's like oh we could buy
this thing for x and sell it for why you
know that that's that's the game plan or
we can make this thing that doesn't
exist and wow look how cool it is look
how it works that was always more fun
and it's just like a level up a
progression in the game to be able to
understand
how do i a keep more money that i make
and b how do we leverage money so that
we could do more interesting things you
know in a less dilutive way so so i i
think these people are amazing you know
like xavier who who runs in during
ventures he told me this once he's just
he was just like you know
if i died i'd be reincarnated as a cfo
not a ceo
and i was so funny it was like the
weirdest brag i've ever heard i was i
never heard somebody like bragging about
wanting to be a cfo and i was like what
do you mean he's like he's like i don't
know i just really like
learning about how to be efficient and
smart on this like financial like
financial engineering and he had done
you know real engineering before that he
built basically like he's like so he
built a solar company in in africa the
largest solar company in africa that's
so funny that he's interested in that
stuff though
he's like a hippie
he's totally a hippie right he did that
because he's like dude there's people
suffering in africa like i wanna
like that seems like the problem to go
fix
but then along the way he's like all
right well
how do i create you know how do i
finance all of these solar panels and
battery packs without having to go raise
venture capital and so in order to do
that like the necessary evil was he
needed to learn how to access cheat debt
he needed to learn how to like issue
debt and underwrite for other people
because what he did was he was like you
know these people should basically they
don't have the 21 dollars to buy the
solar panel that goes on top of their
house that's going to power their fridge
and like if they don't have a fridge
their life really is tough and they need
this but they can't afford the 21 so
like let's just do it at 4 a month or
whatever and like i will underwrite a
loan against their like income and it's
like how do you underwrite a loan for
somebody who doesn't even have
electricity in their house and he would
figure these things out and so i think
it became a necessary evil and something
he got fascinated with and so now
they're doing this whole holding company
and so he does this this one thread he
did went viral which was like how to
have a holding company like warren
buffett and basically like you know make
a massive amount of money pay as little
taxes you need to and like you know have
have more and more money to do
acquisitions as you go
and he basically outlines warren
buffett's corporate structure and why
that's at why that's advantageous and uh
you know i read it and i still only
understand 25 of it but i'm just glad
that there's people like that that i can
go to whenever i have a question
hilarious
dude that's great well i like this guy
got him i'm gonna i want to learn more
about him you have more on him or you
want me to go uh i have another person
like this all right another person and
idea like this okay so now let's switch
gears
another creative titan that we talked
about mr beast so we hung out with mr
beast i don't know if you guys are sick
of us talking about that yet but you
know uh producer ben is literally
sitting here in a mr beast uh t-shirt so
you know he's a fan
uh but that's good ben because you know
when we were sitting in that meeting and
they brought in the swag
uh jimmy who who is mr bc he goes oh man
they're not like kids dude they don't
they don't need the stuff like you know
they're not gonna be
because the guy came in was like guys i
got treats for you and he's like had a
bunch of swag and nobody moved and miss
jimmy was like oh no they don't care
about this stuff man they're they're
adults and then like all of us were like
the [__] you talking about dude and like
we're just like i just like i literally
rolled my chair over to him like you
know like a kid i'm like
i like just rolled my rolling chair over
to that part of the table because it was
like a long boardroom and i was just
like i'm going to get some swag and i
went and got it and the other guy was
like i got kids man they're gonna need
like if i don't bring back swag they're
gonna be pissed and so and now ben is
wearing his damn i jimmy drove me like
when we were going to the i took a ride
with them and i found that shirt that
you're wearing ben in the back of his
car and i just go i'm [__] taking
this he's got tons of them so i stole
mine from him i i didn't know that we
had the opportunity to take it like
ethically
never considered that
um so jimmy okay so i wanted to bring
something up that he had talked about
that we didn't mention on the podcast
which to me is the most interesting
business that this guy has
you might be thinking is the most
interesting business his youtube channel
no
is it his chocolate company feast named
feastables no
is it his
shipping burger company his cloud
kitchen called mr beastberger no
do you know which one i'm going to talk
about either you guys know give me a sam
about
i think
ben do you have any idea which one i
might be referring to uh well
uh no but are you gonna talk about his
burger did you guys see his restaurant
just open
yeah yeah but let's talk about this
other thing okay okay no no no i don't
know you're not like i wrote down what i
think it is and then you you say all
it's his
like kind of translation
internationalization company translation
sam got it there it is
this idea is amazing so when we're
sitting there he's like yeah i got
basically whatever the number
one number two whatever biggest channel
in in america and he's like pulling up
his like youtube stats on he's like
airplaying onto the tv like his youtube
stats
and then he goes um i also have this
channel in portugal this my portuguese
channel is growing really fast
and he puts up a video it's got 20
million views in brazil
and i was like and it starts talking and
all of a sudden he's talking in fluent
portuguese and i was like what is this
he's like oh yeah like it like ai
no so what they did was they were like
look one of the things we already put a
million and a half dollars into this
video where i built this chocolate
factory and i'm gonna give it away to
one of these people
how do we get more juice out of that
fruit and so what they realized was we
can go international into markets where
youtube is huge like brazil
um brazil's got this massive population
it's huge on youtube
and they don't have content like mr
beast is doing like he's ahead of the
game for the us he's light years ahead
of the game for like brazil or the
philippines or different places like
this and so but the challenge is it's a
language challenge so what they did was
they went they basically hired somebody
to create a youtube channel they said
hey you're going to be our youtube
channel manager for this country you're
the country manager for brazil you've
got to have our twitter our tick tock
our youtube all of it um you know mr
brazil or whatever it's called then
secondly we're gonna when we have a
video here you need to get it translated
by a local like like a dubbing service
so like a local translator and i want it
translated i want the description
translated i want uh all of it done
and then you upload it there you respond
to the comments you manage that
community all of that good stuff and
what they did was they would not like
they didn't just go get like you know
some random crappy person on fiverr to
do it they got like the guy who dubbed
spider-man in
in brazil they got him to do the voice
acting for this they paid him a lot of
money they paid him like a couple
hundred grand and i was like i feel like
you didn't need to do that you could
have just got anybody and he's like
check this out like basically you don't
know [__] about [__] sean and so he goes
to the comments and every comment is
oh my god mr beast is spider-man like
they just thought he must be that guy
like that's him that's that voice i
recognize and so he got like all this
extra you know social juice it was a
little more remarkable and again back to
our principle from last podcast which is
just do the doper thing just do the dope
[__] instead of the lame [__] yeah yeah
what's cooler
the cheaper guy from fiverr or
all right you paid 100 or whatever you
got spider-man to do it it's like yeah
of course of course what what am i
thinking and so that's true
by the way
when i listen to audio books like on
audible i ever if i if i see a famous
person's the author or the narrator
rather i listen to it so like i'm
listening to huckleberry finn not that i
really care about huckleberry finn but
nick offerman is the narrator you know
the guy from community uh you know who
that is
he's like yeah is he the main guy
community yeah ron swanson he plays like
an angry like white country guy or like
it'll be another guy like it'll be just
like whenever i see an author who i
write a narrator if i recognize her a
famous person i listen to it so tom
hanks doing divi code i didn't really
want to do davinci code but tom hanks so
like the whole narrator thing yeah
that's pretty sick i'm on board with
that
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
so so basically what he's done is he's
like cool now
that's okay so he was doing that for
himself so he's like oh good i'm i'm
blowing up in romania i'm blowing up in
the philippines i'm blowing up in brazil
i'm blowing up everywhere he's like i
already did 80 of the work it's that
last 20
that is foreign to me feels feels like a
lot of work whatever but all i can hire
the people to do this but the smart part
was he's like this is not just a way for
me to expand my brand that's already a
smart business move he then created this
as a service
for other big youtubers so now if you're
whoever you know your airac or your your
you know some yes theory or something
like that right you could basically just
use his service he'll just go to you and
be like hey do you want to be big in
brazil we'll just do all the work for
you and like we'll keep like 30 of their
ad revenue and they're like that's crazy
okay yeah like i'm not gonna hire i'm
not gonna go and do this interview
process to hire all these people and
figure it out and manage this all myself
that's kind of inefficient but what he
can do is like he can have one team
in brazil that's gonna manage 15
youtubers channels there
and so
i think this is one of the smartest
businesses that he has i think it's
going to be one of the most successful
it's going to be pure profit essentially
and um i think he's got the distribution
locked down because if he goes to any
youtuber and explains hey here's what
i'm doing and you get access to my
machine they're all going to say yes
and it's a it's a good idea for them
it's a win-win for them because they're
just not going to capture this extra
value
and so he's doing this and is just
another example of
turning a cost center into a profit
center and i actually want to talk about
some examples of those so basically
things where
this would normally just be a cost to
him to run this to have all these people
on staff but once he turns it into a
service for other youtubers now it
becomes a profit center and so there's
which bunch of pixels which i think this
would make way more money than the
chocolate bars like i remember i ate the
chocolate the chocolate that he had and
i was like well you know like hey
it's good but i don't it's not like that
different than any other chocolate that
i've had and
b
it kind of sucks that i've got to feel
bad about myself if i consume a lot of
your product and see it's only like 40
it was 40 i think for a box like it's
hard to build a big business 40 a pop
you know what i'm saying at least when
you're not if you got to be in walmart
or something
yeah which i'm sure he could do also
like
ben's point he he opened up a brick and
mortar location for his burger joint and
normally you're like ah you know opening
up a restaurant a mall maybe not the
best idea and then he like post this
video there's like literally i don't
know 50 000 people in the mall like
lined up it was like people were lined
up up and down each concourse just like
you know
the restaurants on floor one or whatever
like people were on floor four
just lined up in this line and it was
insane so you know this guy's got pretty
massive pull so what are the other
examples of of turnover
so the first one that came to mind for
me was aws so aws today is basically
amazon amazon's most of its profits come
from aws and aws is basically when
amazon had to have a really robust set
of servers to run their own website and
then they were like
hey the way we use this kind of like
server infrastructure and it's just like
this big expense for us to have this
server farm what if we just rented this
out to other companies who want to have
like amazon level servers without having
to go rack their own servers in some
data center and that became aws and
basically aws spits off billions and
billions in profit now what started as
what would have been a billion dollar
loss and so you know that's a huge swing
but i have some others uh that i want to
explain to you so
michael gurdley who came on the pod he
goes
my favorite is
um this company called freight alley
they did what what hubspot kind of did
with the hustle they basically have this
thing called freight waves which is
freight waves is basically a
media company
and freight alley is the
like the sas company so basically
they're a sas company that created a
media arm
that goes and uh normally a media
companies you know has expenses but they
turn it into a profit center basically
that acquires customers for the sas
business at a negative customer
acquisition cost so the media company is
profitable and brings in
customers to their own sas you know at
the bottom of the funnel so that's one
example not exactly the full thing but
dude another guy the guy who started
that company his name's craig i've hung
out with him a bit he
um
bought a big piece of property in
tennessee and he's the one who's turning
it into like an airport it's like a
country club but instead of a golf
course there's an airport so he's
selling he bought a huge plot of land
now he's sub-selling or he's selling
smaller pots of land and there's going
to be an airplane strip and a hangar
that everyone has access to so if you're
a flying enthusiast you buy a home there
and you can use this and he bought
a magazine i think it was called
airplane.com or something like that he
bought a magazine and he's like i'm
going to buy a magazine and do the same
thing that i did but instead of software
we're going to do it with these houses
wow that's
amazing another
another example so
any ddc company that eventually takes
their own warehouse and starts
fulfilling for other customers so they
turn their own warehouse which is a cost
for them for fulfillment into a profit
center because they're doing fulfillment
for themselves and others very similar
to aws okay here's another one uh this
guy george on twitter just sent me this
he goes
ford decided to own the timber supply
for their vehicles so there was lots of
wood in the early cars
they ended up with so much leftover wood
they started selling charcoal and that's
kingsford charcoal
company that's my favorite man that's my
favorite story
that's a that's kind of amazing i didn't
know that uh is there more to know about
that or did we kind of nail it there no
you nailed it so basically they were
so ford was making frame car frames and
they had to burn a whole lot of wood in
order to you know bend the steel or do
whatever they had to do and they had all
this leftover charred wood and they're
like what do we do with this and i think
it was henry ford's idea i forget
exactly whose idea but he goes hey let's
let's start selling this let's make
something out of this and that's where
it kind of came from there's a bunch of
entrepreneurs that have kind of like
done things like this uh standard oil
did something like this where they're
like
this gets more complicated and is less
interesting but like hey this off put of
kerosene is like this weird like fluid
that's like really greasy is there
anything we could do with that and like
wd-40 or something like that right like
they've like there's like stories like
that with with standard oil as well
and so here's a couple others so
foursquare foursquare had an api for
businesses because they needed all this
data
about businesses where they're located
all that stuff and they needed that for
to power their own foursquare app and
foursquare kind of went up and this hype
cycle that went down many years sort of
forgotten sort of written off but a new
ceo joined and almost oriented the
company around this it was like look the
more valuable thing is not people using
foursquare in the app and playing the
game it's all the data we've collected
about businesses where they're located
with like hyper precision
and so we actually just need to make
that api available to everybody and they
productize the api and they make i think
more money off the ap i think they make
more money off the api than they do off
the core app at this point um so so i
think that's that's another great
example of this amazon has a bunch like
amazon was a book seller right so their
main cost of goods sold was their books
but then they create kindle and kindle
self and the self-publishing business
and the public and all that and so now
kindle itself became a profit center
what so it used to be a cost which was
selling books now they sell ebooks that
they kind of own
and um you know they turn that profit
same thing with payments right amazon
had to pay a a merchant like a fee every
time they processed a payment so they
created their own payment software
amazon called amazon payments and now
like you know for our e-com store i just
went i was like i think we take amazon
payments where does that money go and i
went and found an account we have with
amazon payments i had like 400 grand
sitting in it because we used that
service amazon payments to take payments
for somebody who wants to pay with
amazon and so they turned it into a
profit center along the way that's crazy
another one is um slack
so slack started out as a game and when
they were working on their game
they it wasn't actually doing that well
but they created a way in order to
communicate effectively with their with
their co-workers and they said ah [__]
this game this thing's actually way
cooler let's actually turn this internal
tool into a
a proper tool we thought about doing
that so here's but here's the problem
with this this all sounds sick
a lot of people
say yeah let's do this and so a lot of
publishers are doing this and so they
are like let's sell our cms so buzzfeed
vox
washington post i forget who else is
like they build these custom website
builders and they say let's sell this
and i think oftentimes it's a
distraction and they always say well
amazon did it and i looked into this
amazon did launch aws
uh pretty early on but you know how many
employees they had when they did it
how many total employees are on aws yeah
total employees there's about five
thousand so they were already a
multi-billion dollar company with it and
so they the way the story is told is
like oh they were just this little guy
no they had about 5 000 people when they
launched aws like it was like a you know
it was a it was a thing it wasn't just
like a scrappy startup and a lot of
times people like will say well let's
also sell this it's like dog we've got
eight people working here like who's
gonna do this
uh so that's always like i've always
been conflicted with this strategy
yeah that's that's true uh you guys
considered it you would have done it for
what is it your
um our email sending platform so like we
built our own for a little while and
then we made it really easy so like if
so basically
hypothetically which there aren't that
many people doing this if you had a
daily email it was really easy for you
to talk to your advertiser make the ad
and insert into the thing have them
approve it and like it was simple and
easy to use but the problem is is like
they're not that many people doing it
you know what i mean and being
then but like beehive basically does
that now
and they're actually growing pretty well
well
maybe i could have been wrong but i
don't think i'm gonna end up being wrong
i think that i think that i'm not
convinced that what they're doing
at least
ads for a daily email that business i
don't think will be ever be that
particularly big and beehive so beehive
is kind of like sub stack
and so it's these services that you get
subscribers and they take a small amount
of revenue based off of how much you're
making from subscriptions or you just
pay them like a fee on how many
subscribers you have do you think that
some of those businesses actually can
become huge venture-backed sized
companies so i just invested in beehive
actually initially i didn't invest
because i was like uh i don't know how
big this gets and then two things sort
of changed my mind
the first is
every time i needed something for
beehive the founder was an absolute
animal on my request like because we use
it for milk road so yeah he's great his
name's tyler he's awesome
tyler was he's like it's already on her
like he'd be like it's already on a road
map the question i have is a or b
there's like nuance about it that shows
he's been thinking about this noodling
on it and then he'd be like
when do you need this buy because
normally like it's scheduled to be out
in three weeks
but if you need three days like you know
the weekend exists i might be able to
you know like whatever so he was able to
like
rip off feature after feature after
feature that we needed
and everything that was like you're like
hey we have this question it's like him
and his team would dig in so he so i saw
that he kind of had that grit that you
like in an entrepreneur so i got to
basically
special which i normally don't get to do
with most investments um you know with
most investments you meet them you do a
call with them they say all the right
things they send you the deck you look
at it you kick you look at the product
and like you got to make an educated
guess at that point you don't get to
spend
months working with the actual
entrepreneur as a customer and see how
quick they are with features how fast
they're responding the quality of the
product all that good stuff
so so that was the first reason the
second reason was
i've come to realize that
the
the best investments i've made have been
ones where what looks like a small
market what looks niche turns out to not
be niche so we got acquired by twitch
and our last company twitch was a kind
of the quintessential example of this
right like yeah but like how many people
are going to watch other people play
video games on the internet like how
many people are going to stream
themselves playing a video game and how
many people want to watch that
looked niche
and turned out to be a massive behavior
this is also true with like you know uh
now shopify seems really obvious i
remember talking to
the vc who led shopify's early rounds uh
you know maybe six seven years ago
and shopify at that point was still like
legit but it's not what it is today it's
not like seen as it is today is like one
of the blue chip startups and it was the
same thing it was like okay you know
like just like etsy like you know how
big do these actually get these kind of
like
indie maker seller type things isn't
amazon and big brands just going to like
dominate this like how many mom and pops
are there going to be on the internet
that can actually do this well and how
much dude i remember that i remember tim
ferriss invested in shopify and he was
talking about it and i was like shopify
that's so silly like you know this thing
exists this exists this exists why don't
you just use this thing and like you
know i remember like i forget what those
were like big commerce do you remember
big commerce there's big commerce
there's woocommerce there's magento
there was all these and so that was
actually a big problem which is if you
looked at the existing ones that had
been around for like 10 years and they
were kind of like
like those are pretty like uh they're
cheaper they're harder they're more
flexible but they're way harder to use
and they were kind of like from a
different era so they kind of like
peaked at a certain point and you look
at those and they're like peaking back
then yeah you're like how big does this
get look that's how big it gets not very
big
and the same thing happened with airbnb
i remember when airbnb was like coming
out and i was like uh well it's couch
surfing but better right like i don't
know if people remember couchsurfing.com
was like one of the early oh that's a
cool idea but it never made a bunch of
money never got huge because again how
many people really want to go
live sleep on a you know someone's couch
or extra bedroom in uh in some city okay
yeah it's this kind of vagabond hippie
traveling [__] but like that's not
mainstream
and so if you looked at couchsurfing to
see how big airbnb could get you're like
well sit very very similar idea been
around for longer seems to have
plateaued around this size not that big
and like you would have been wrong and
so i guess i've kind of learned that
like the absolute biggest wins in
venture
come when you find something non-obvious
and the non-obvious
non-obvious to me typically is like
just fundamentally like product
categories or markets people aren't
going after or markets that other people
think are small that actually are going
to turn out to be very big
there's this really great story with sam
altman who at the time was the president
of uh what's it called y combinator and
brian chesky and brian chesky is getting
or maybe he was just worked at y
combinator and brian chesky in 2005
must have been 2011 was getting ready to
pitch you know so yc you go through this
8 or 12 week incubator at the end you
pitch a bunch of venture capitalists and
yc helps you a bunch of ways including
getting your pitch right brian chesky's
with sam going over his pitch he goes
this company one day is gonna make a
hundred million dollars a year
and sam was like brian like can you just
do me a favor anywhere in this
presentation where you have like a
number could you do me a favor and add a
zero behind it at the end of it guys
change all the m's to bs investors
that's what he does
yeah he goes anything that you have an m
i want to see a b change it all right
and i i don't remember exactly how the
story goes but it was paraphrased in
such words like brian goes like but
that's lying like there's no way that
we're going to do that like it's just
impossible
no one has done this before he goes yeah
but you know it seems like a big market
and here's my reasoning like logically
it makes sense there's so many people
who stay at hotels like of course you
can do this i mean someone can do it i
bet and she'll just do me a favor and
change all those m's to bees and even
brian chesky didn't believe it and
there's another story by the way where i
remember um
what was uh amazon's first vc was it
madonna is that what it's called madonna
it's like it looks like the word madonna
they're based up in seattle and uh he's
pitching and i let's do a podcast with
the guy he pitched and the guy he
pitched tells the story of bezos saying
like look
if we if we get our act together and we
make this work i think we're gonna make
like a hundred million bucks a year in
like the next five or ten years like
that was his pitch is like that's how
big i think we're gonna get and the guy
was like i need to get a lot bigger than
that but whatever you seem really
competent so it's just proof that like
even the people starting things
sometimes also are like i don't know how
big this can get i don't know if this is
going to work out
yeah like there's that clip of mark
zuckerberg talking out of college and
he's like doing a interview campus
interviews like hey we're here with the
campus report and we have mark
zuckerberg the founder of
thefacebook.com
uh which is blowing up around campus
people really like your website mark um
you know he's like he's basically he's
wearing basketball shorts he's got a red
solo cup he's drinking out of yes and
he's just sitting there and they're like
so you've expanded to like whatever
seven colleges
and where you're gonna go from here
you're gonna end up going into high
schools or you know you're gonna how big
can this get he's like
oh i don't know like right now it's
facebook is cool like it's cool for
colleges really really useful and
sometimes if you try to make something
too big like it loses what makes it cool
like maybe it doesn't like
why does it have to be bigger and maybe
it doesn't have to be bigger
he says that and then like you know sure
enough fast forward 10 years he's like
we need to launch a satellite to india
to give these rural villagers internet
more users the facebook yeah we need
more
and so he turns into an absolute animal
by the way this mma clip of zuck
awesome seen this
awesome killed it he killed it he killed
it so for the background on this uh
zuck went on rogan and talked about a
bunch of stuff it was it was actually a
pretty good interview i think zucker
actually kind of redeemed himself a bit
but uh in in part of the interview zuck
said i've been training mma and people
are like afterwards yeah right okay nerd
he posts this video of him training he
looks really good way faster than i
thought he was going to be like fighting
he was fighting i was like
even if he wasn't good the fact that he
does this it's just like i basically
this was my tipping point i already
liked zuck
but now i'm team zuck which there's not
a lot of us here right we can't even
play a game of pickup basketball there's
four of us on team suck we're just still
looking for a fifth and
as somebody tweeted this out they were
they they go
jack dorsey um you know because jack
dorsey uh hasn't worked in 10 years uh
constantly like constantly meditating uh
you know dating different models no
family tries to run multiple companies
at once fails
twitter never makes anybody blah blah
blah
zuck
you know begrudgingly runs a trillion
dollar empire
you know faithfully monogamous uh great
dad uh trains mma like all these like
it's like jack dorsey doesn't work out
it's like sucked trains mma and it just
like highlights like you know basically
like why does everybody hate this guy
again like what is this guy done like
you know
and and some people are like you he
ruined democracy he's like no dude he
built basically the modern telephone and
you're pissed that some people make
phone calls that you don't like that's
that's basically what happens on
facebook is that he built the app
everybody uses to communicate everything
stupid or amazing
and sure enough some percentage of that
is not content you like and it's not
controllable and the guys literally
built like
it was at a trillion dollars at a point
in time he's built a trillion dollar
company
and he just keeps running it he keeps
trying to make it better and he keeps
trying to push the envelope and he keeps
trying to make like better and better
products and services and do you think
he really cares
about like do you think he sits there
being like i want to influence the
election but no that's like
you know that's the that's a pain in the
ass he's trying to deal with it's not
like his agenda people make him out to
be like this evil guy and it's like dude
people people don't like him because
he's awkward
like all right you're a bully if you
don't like him because he's a hurt you
know like think about who you are if you
don't like mark zuckerberg you're a
bully you just think he's awkward and
that's how you judge him like screw you
man the guy's awesome we should do we
should do like an entire episode about
this because there was one beautiful
line that he said so rogan was like
um look like you had these russians
doing this and influencing the election
and then the hunter biden story story
came out and you guys like took it down
and you told them it wasn't allowed and
then and like rogan was like uh
criticizing him or at least voicing all
the criticisms that facebook had and
marco's um
yeah look like
how would you handle that situation
and
love to see you dude
it goes
i don't know and
zuck's like yeah we didn't either and so
our reasoning was like we like took down
the hunter like i don't even remember
how he explained he's like well our
reasoning was this this and this well he
was like did the fbi came to us told us
there's about to be a story that could
be massive misinformation and go viral
we just basically they just got their
wrist slapped because they previously
let other information spread too fast
that they said you should have known
that was fake news you should have
stopped it so now the fbi comes to you
and says there's about to be a dump of
fake news that's going to go viral
so what do they do they're like okay we
shouldn't just like i guess we shouldn't
block the news but maybe we should like
suppress it in the news feed so that it
doesn't go super viral because of you
know isn't that what we just got in
trouble for i don't know he didn't say
all this but like it's obvious this is
obviously what what would you do the fbi
comes to you and says it's about to be a
misinformation leak and then it it comes
out and sure enough it starts going
viral you have to decide do we just let
this take over the platform and like
oops we did it again
or like should we play it safe and like
not let this spread like wildfire until
we can fact check this and see if this
is real or not like by the time it does
one side the left or right is gonna be
mad at you and it's like if you just
think about this [__] it's like
the person who in 2016 was like
the election was rigged the russians
manipulated the election
then he fast forward to 2020 biden wins
and then the the right is now like the
election was rigged biden was counting
votes that didn't count you know like
it's like they're both just like they
just switched you're the same you're the
same dude on either side of the aisle
like don't you realize that you're it's
like the spider-man meme they're
pointing at each other yeah it's the
same thing over and over and over again
it's like um you know she's got you know
the bad thing on her server it's like
he's got the documents in mar-a-lago and
it's like they just keep doing this you
know left and right so how is a
communication platform supposed to win
because literally no matter what you do
one side is going to think you're being
completely unfair or the other there's
no
such a good job though that is such a
good answer and he like humanized
himself so much there and he goes we did
we our reasoning was and he said exactly
we said about the fbi doing this and
this is what we thought seemed right at
the time how would you have hated that
joe and joe was like
well that's a good question i guess i
would call someone who i think knows the
answer and just talk and listen to him
he goes yeah that's what we did you know
we called these people we talked to them
and this is the best that we did and
could it have been wrong maybe but like
you know we don't really know the right
answer and it kind of i realized like oh
wow this guy zuck he's 38 years old he's
36 years old like he's in his thir his
mid 30s
been doing this since he was 21. like
he's just making it up and trying
to make some good decisions along the
way is he maybe a little evil
maybe but we all got a little bit of us
in that we all have a little bit of that
and like he's mostly doing a good job
and it just he did a really good turn
that question of well how would you have
handled it that was such a beautiful way
because it was like oh you're
you're fallible you're just like me you
know like we're not that different is he
a ruthless competitor in the sport of
business sure
i wouldn't expect somebody who's number
one in their game to not be a religious
competitor at their game like i wouldn't
expect them to be a softy
who who doesn't care or you know what i
mean like it's insane to be that people
hold this like this crazy standard other
reasons i'm team suck so
you know about his like once a year
missions that he does
yeah like one year it was like travel
the country in an rv
uh yeah so he did he that was like when
it was like election time he's like i
need to i don't know i need to meet
middle america uh i'm going to like you
know
i will visit places with walmart's like
you know that's like his mission for the
year that year dude by the way i respect
when people do that so much i was
watching this music video with mike
poser you know mike posner and you
probably love him
you know how he walked across the
country
yeah so he like followed it yeah it was
yeah it was awesome
he got bit by rattlesnake
yeah and he like he got bit by
rattlesnake and he had to go home for
two weeks and learn to walk again and
then he shipped right back out to where
he was and he went to you know he's like
this guy who you imagine as being this
like california cool kid guy or a new
york cool kid guy and he ends up walking
the country and he's like i walked
around places with confederate flags i
went to like rural kansas i went
everywhere and i saw america and i
realized that like i don't know [__]
about america these people are a lot
different than i thought and it was
really nice to get to know like other
types of people i love when people do
that and so i'm team zuck a little bit
because he did that
he so he did that but the first ones he
did i feel like were things that he was
actually just self-interested in so he
um i remember one of his first ones was
that he was going to only
eat if he was going to eat meat it had
to be meat that he had personally hunted
so he's like i've never hunted i think
he'd like never hunted before and he's
like i don't really know where my food
comes from or like what goes into this
showing up on my plate
and i want to like actually like with my
hands i want to experience this entire
process so he had to hunt it he had to
like prep it or kill like you know clean
it or whatever and cook it and then eat
it and so that's what he did for one
year one year he was just like
i want to learn mandarin i think
facebook really wanted to go into china
so he's like he showed up in china to
give a talk he did the whole thing in
mandarin and surprised the [__] out of
the whole crowd they were like
it was like you know the scene in eight
mile where he's going off on in the rap
battle it was like the whole crowd was
like oh what's going on like
he's just speaking fluent mandarin with
like the proper tone and like
dude what a machine to in his like spare
time just pick up these hobbies and then
do them and now he's doing like mma and
biology who's a you know a friend of
ours he he he tweeted this out he goes
it has begun
i forgot who he said he goes first uh
great line it has begun we could say
that for so many things that's a
beautiful those are beautiful first
words he called it he called it uh he
goes first
first bezos now zuck i'm seeing it
across the board
tech people starting to seriously lift
and train testosterone replacement
therapy quantified self optimal diet
diet eventually this will be productized
for all but transhumanism starts with
personal chatification
because personal chat if occasionally
turning yourself into an absolute chad
and i know you i don't know if you saw
this tweet or not but every word of this
you know you were just doing the the the
you're at the black church saying you
know you're the gospel
the choir of donda academy is singing
and you're like amen to this right like
because you've been doing this right
you've been doing you're doing this for
about five years now i've been becoming
chat and you want to know something it
is awesome
it is so awesome i i've influenced you a
little bit to you've slowly become into
it it's the way to live man yeah i'm not
like a chad i'm like a um like i know
charles right now like i need to become
a chad i'm just i'm just slowly working
i'm like a bret trying to get trying to
get to chad right now
dude just like lifting this sounds so
i don't care how it sounds it is what it
is lifting heavy weight and then just
like eating meat and vegetables i just
feel happy i feel good about my life and
i look at all pictures of us when we
were recording the podcast at my office
and my face was so much more round and
i'm disgusted i'm like you are such a
[__] filthy animal you are filthy you
are a horrible human being and i look at
myself it has made me so much happier
and like i'm i'm i'm pumped that the
nerves are finding out about it
yeah i think balaji lifts i think he
power lifts as well so uh so yeah
there's just like there's so much
research that shows
dude like being stronger it just makes
uh they say you know a strong body a
strong mind like when getting stronger
like there's so many benefits to living
a longer life uh what's his name what's
the what's the guy we like the hunk
scientist
yeah humor man don't act like you don't
know
for the record we never have referred to
him like that in private which is why i
was confused you acted like we always
call him the hunk scientist and text
message
dude i have a friend that like went and
got in a cold plunge with him and he
goes he's ripped like he's jacked and
i'm like yeah of course these guys are
like made for one like how close
together were they
occupancy of one
that's a new protocol you got to sit on
top one another
that's what he's telling people he's
like uh hey uh
you know if you uh sit right here on my
lap you're gonna live like an extra hour
but my dude my friend did a thing with
him but he goes he's just jacked and uh
uh i i don't even remember how we start
talking about this but he he did a
podcast the other day he talked about
like living longer and he's like yeah
lift weights and go for runs and you'll
like and you'll live longer so i'm happy
you probably do this stuff my trainer
has been doing this stuff called
myofascial car myofascial release or
something like that do you do this like
a like a massage it's basically foam
rolling but on steroids i go to a doctor
two days a week and get it done in my
calves
yeah i knew i knew you would do this as
a as a as a full chad you you of course
are like you know
all the way in on this
it's basically he has these like like
these trigger point balls and like these
like different like
torture devices i'll call them and he's
like all right so
i've done foam rolling before it's it's
okay it's kind of boring a little bit
painful um not the most fun thing in the
world and you know it was always
recommended to me like hey just you know
you should foam roll tomorrow morning or
tonight you know that'll help you with
your soreness i was like yeah you know
sure right after i eat my broccoli and
asparagus and like you know you know say
my prayers and get to bed by 9 p.m like
of course yeah i'll also foam roll why
not
add it to the other list of [__] i'm not
gonna do that i shouldn't do it and so
with this we do we now
he who he got me to do is like the first
25 minutes of every workout we're doing
this so he'll be like all right find
this spot like in your hip flexor and
take this like rock hard ball and you're
just gonna like put all your body weight
on that thing and wherever it feels most
painful
that's the spot i'm like oh my god he's
like he's like he'll hear me like
basically wincing and groaning in pain
and he's like all right cool just you
found it now stay there for three and a
half minutes i'm like three and a half
minutes like and so this has turned out
to be i bring this up because hey i find
it interesting i think there's a lot of
fitness movements that have a business
like angle to them and i feel like
you've been ahead of the curve on a lot
of this like
uh you were on atg or the kind of like
knees over toes stuff before most people
and in general like what do you call it
movement therapy or something movement
yeah mobility mobility training
this myofascial cardio released like i
think this is also like an area where
the the puck is going and more people
are going to be well it's like and you
feel good amazing as soon as it's done
right like you feel absolutely amazing
um when it's done but the
the part of it that i find interesting
is basically
i for me working out is not like i want
to get as jacked and shredded as
possible it's basically like
i want a part of my day where i'm not at
my computer sitting down i'm not on my
phone i'm not even thinking about work
and i know that could be other things it
could be meditation or whatever but like
a way a way more achievable form of
meditation for me is exercise
exercise where i basically i'm only
focused on the thing that's right in
front of me like being absolutely
present because there's like
a giant weight that's about to fall on
my face or hurt i'll hurt my shoulder or
i'll injure myself or i'm like in
extreme pain doing this like trigger
point massage or whatever and i'm not i
can't go anywhere else i can't think
about the past i can't fantasize about
the future
i can't worry about what notification
just buzzed on my phone and i'm just
like out of it for at least one hour a
day and for me that became the real like
benefits of this
more than like oh you know i'm getting
more fit or i have more energy or
whatever it's like it forces me to do
that like
the like the real version of meditation
so that's what i like about it the most
dude i told you what scott galloway said
right
he's like what did you say the whole
point
he said this in an interview and i
thought it was amazing as as like i've
been trying to say that but you just
said it so much better he said in an
interview with ryan holiday he goes
basically i think the whole like if you
are not
fit enough that you can
kill and eat most people in the room or
outrun them then you have a problem and
you should like work
he's like i pretty much just exercise
just so i can kill and eat most people
in a room or just be able to outrun them
and he said that i was like oh yeah
that's actually that's the way to go
that's the way to live no that is so
stupid that's the part where i'm like
okay i don't even want to be a part of
this movement anymore like why is that
the how is that even relevant that's
like saying you know i want to be fast
in case an asteroid is going to hit the
earth and i got to get out of the way
it's like what are you talking about
what is this scenario where you need to
eat and kill or run away from everybody
in the room has this ever no
entire lifetime happen that's that's at
all not like it's like it's more like
why does a car need to go 120 miles an
hour when the speed limit 60. like it
just doesn't because it's just it
doesn't know but it's awesome that it
does and because it can that makes it
just a little bit cooler are you ever
going to drive 160 miles an hour no of
course not but like i still want that
ferrari just cause i want to know i can
do it and like the act of training to
get to be able to do it is awesome so do
i intend to eat you ah tbd probably not
but like it's cool that i could like if
i wanted to i could do x y and z to you
and just training for that i think is
awesome
i would taste horrible like if you're
gonna eat somebody i'm not your guy you
know dude i heard the best place to eat
someone is there is like their thumb
right here i heard that's like
that does it does actually look like a
chicken drumstick actually now that you
think about it right like that little
that little section
yeah i i i heard that's the best part uh
i always thought half would be the way
to go because that looks like the giant
like turkey leg at disneyland i thought
i thought yeah that would be where i
would muscular parts muscular parts
aren't good you know you want fat the
fatter the part is is the better your
calves are pretty lean compared to the
rest of your body just your butt
basically then you're gonna eat your
butt and your belly yeah your red pork
belly man that's just good it is it's
amazing
salmon belly fantastic and pretty much
any belly
yeah i'm a belly guy all right
i think we've gone off the rails
we started with kanye and we ended
with eating each other what part of each
other would we want to eat
uh
[Music]
you